uh thank you for tuning in to this talk
uh today i will be talking about the
strong issue planted click hypothesis
and its consequences
and this joy worked with aria rubinstein
and cylius strum
both of them are from stanford
university
so in the planet greek problem we
consider the following two distributions
the first one is the distribution g n
and half
which is simply the uniform distribution
over
all graphs with n vertices equivalently
you can think of this distribution as
each edge in the graph being present
with probability one half independently
another distribution that we consider is
the planted distribution
in this distribution the graph is first
generated the same as before using gn
and a half
but then we add with a random kappa
size clean for example maybe this is the
graph we generated from gn and a half
if kappa is three we would pick three
random vertices so maybe these are the
three vertices
so we add the edge between them so that
they become a kept barclay
in the planted greek problem we are
presented with a graph
g which comes from either g n and a half
or
the planted distribution and our goal is
to
distinguish between the two specifically
if g
come from the formal distribution we
wanna output
random with probability say at least two
thirds
and if if it comes from the planted
distribution
we want to output planted with
probability at least
two thirds
several algorithms are known for the
painted clique problem
the simplest algorithm explains the fact
that
in gn and half the size of the largest
click
concentrates around two times log in
this means that we can try to enumerate
to try
and find a clique of size significantly
larger than two times log n
if we find one then we know that
g likely comes from the planted
distribution
so this gives us an algorithm that runs
in
into the order of log n time
and this works for any value of kappa
furthermore when kappa is too large
specifically if kappa is
at least the order of square root n is
also known that
the problem can be solved in polynomial
time
however below this ratio of square root
n
it is not known whether the problem is
solvable in polynomial time
and many researchers in fact believe
that
when k is little of square root n
planetary cannot be solved in polynomial
time
and this is formalized in the so-called
planted clique hypothesis
so in recent years the planet click
hypothesis has been used
as a basis to prove many hardness
results
including an inapproximability result
for
densest sub graph so recall here that in
the densest case subgraph problem
we are given a graph and an integer k
and we would like to find a sub graph of
size k that contains as many edges
as possible it has also been used to
prove hardness for the base nash
equilibrium
and also for some more average case
problems such as
bus pca and many more
so in this work we are proposing a
variant of the planet click hypothesis
which postulates the following
for kappa that is a sufficiently small
polynomial in
n so here throughout this talk i will
just write into the point one here but
you can replace point one by
any sufficiently small constant
then uh the planted clique problem
cannot be solved even in into a little
of block n time
in other words we are saying that for
this range of kappa
there is no algorithm that achieves
significant speed up
compared to the brute force algorithm
that we discussed
earlier we call this hypothesis the
strong ish planted click hypothesis
and for those of you who are familiar
with the exponential time hypothesis and
the
strong exponential time hypothesis here
the reason that we don't call it the
strong planetary hypothesis is that in
the strong
eth we would also specify the
constant in the exponent whereas here
we're not specifying the constant so it
is more akin to the exponential time
hypothesis
compared to the strong exponential time
hypothesis
so having stated the hypothesis let me
note that there are few evidences
in the form of lower bounds that can be
viewed as supporting
the hypothesis in particular
barrack and l show that if you take the
natural sum of square relaxation
for the planted clique problem then it
cannot be used to refuse
the strong each planetary hypothesis
similar low bounds are also known for
statistical query algorithms
since sum of squares and statistical
queries are
a large family of algorithms that
encompass many of the known techniques
this suggests that refuting the strong
expanded click hypothesis
is hard and is possibly out of reach of
the
currently known techniques
okay so hopefully i have convinced you
that this hybrid
is at least plausible let us now move on
to discuss what we can
actually prove using this hypothesis so
the result that we can achieve
assuming the strongest pentagon
hypothesis
can be divided into two groups first is
tight hardness of approximation results
and second is tight running time lower
bounds
the main result in the former
is for the densest case of graph problem
where we show that there is no
polynomial time
little of k approximation algorithm for
the problem
and note that the approximation ratio a
little of k
that we can prove here is tight because
there is a simple
algorithm that can achieve k
approximation
for the problem in linear time where you
just
pick a vertex with highest degree
and pick as many of its neighbor
as you can
now using this result and known
reductions in literature
we get tight harness of approximation
results
for many problems including the
smallest kh subgraph problem the steiner
k-4 race problem
and the director directed steiner
network problem
or which we get little of square root k
hardness approximation ratio and also
for the density k
sub hypergraph problem where we prove 2
to the leader of k
1 is our approximation uh
i will not go into details of previous
work on each of these problems here
since
each of them has a pretty long history
but if you are interested in learning
more
please check out the full version of the
paper where we have summarized
the previous works on each of the
problem
on the thai running time low bound front
our
main result is that there is no end to a
little k
time algorithm that can achieve constant
approximation ratio
for the densest case subgraph problem
and notice here that the running time
low bound is tight
because there is a trivial into the
order of
k time algorithm for density k subgraph
that just
enumerates to all the possible
subsets of vertices of size k
so using this result we can prove tight
running time lower bound
for graph pattern detection problems
so in this problem we are given a graph
pattern which is just a graph
of size k and we are given a host graph
which is
a much larger graph of size n and the
goal is to find whether
the host graph contains the pattern
there are two versions of this problem
the first one
is when the pattern has to be an induced
subgraph
in the host graph and the second version
is when
the pattern can be any sub graph
and not necessarily induced subgraph of
the host graph
so in the first version the induced
version we can show enter a little of k
time lower bound for any k vertex
pattern on the other hand for the
not necessarily induced pattern we can
show that this running time low run
holds
for most uh k vertex patterns
i would like to quickly note here that
of our lower bounds also hold for
fpt algorithms so this means that even
if we allow the running time of the
algorithms to depend as any function of
k such as exponential in k or doubly
exponential in k
even our results still hold there
since all the lower bounds that we
discussed here
follow um from reductions of the two top
lower bounds we'll be focusing only on
those two
for the rest of this talk and moreover
in fact these top two low bound are
proof using the exact same reduction and
the exact same proof
just with slightly different choices of
parameter
okay so now let us discuss about this
common reduction between these two
hardness results
so here i just copy the two hardness
results
from the previous slide for convenience
in our reduction
we will start from the planted clique
problem so in the us case our graph
g will be sampled from the planted
distribution where here our kappa is
n to the point one and in the no case
g will be sampled from the random dn
and a half distribution our reduction
has three parameters
k l and n and it will produce
a graph g prime with the following
properties
in the us case g prime will with large
probability say 0.9
contains a k clip whereas in the no case
again with large probability any k
vertex subset of g prime will have
a small number of edges specifically the
bound we will get is
order of k times log n over l
and the size of the graph or the number
of vertices of the graph
g prime will be big n
which in our reduction will always
choose to be
n to the order of l
now recall that the strong each planted
clay hypothesis give a running time
lower bound of
n to the omega of log n of the
starting planet click problem and since
the
size of the new problem big n is just
the original n
to the order of l we now get a running
time low bound of big n
to the omega of log n over l
and for the inapproximability ratio
notice that in the yes case there is a
solution which is the k
click that has order of k square edges
whereas in the nokias we have an upper
bound of k times log n over l edges on
any solution
so we get an inapproximability ratio
of k times l divided by log
n so once we have this reduction
it's pretty simple to derive our two
main hardness results
specifically for the first one we may
pick out to be a little
of log n here we get in approximability
ratio of little of k and a running time
lower bound of n to the omega one
uh this means that no polynomial time
algorithm achieves
approximation ratio of little of k for
density k sub graph
for the ladder we can pick l to be some
constant times log n over
k so this will give us constant in a
probability
ratio and running time low bound of n to
the
omega of k so in other words there is no
enthalpy of k
times algorithm that achieved constant
approximation ratio
for density k subgraph
okay so with that in mind we only have
to describe this reduction
and prove its property
so this reduction is the so-called
randomized graph products
which has been used since at least the
late 80s by
burman and schnitzger and the reduction
works as follows
so recall that we start with a graph g
and we have parameters k l and n
what we will do is first we will pick
n random subsets of vertices
of g s 1 to s n
each having l vertices
and then we'll construct one vertex in d
prime
for each of this subset and we add an
edge between two subsets s i and sj
even only if the union induce
a click in the original graph g
for example here is a a possible
construction
if our l is equals to 2 we will pick s1
to
sn to be random subset of size
2 from the vertices of the original
graph g so maybe we pick s1 to be
v2 e3 s2 to bb1 v2 and s3 to bv3 v5
so we will then go and create one vertex
for each subset in g
prime and then for each pair
we will consider their union and see
whether
is a click in g for example in s1 and s2
the union is
v1 v2 and v3 which is not a click in the
original graph g
because v 1 and v 2 doesn't have an h
there
so we do not add this h on the other
hand
s 1 and s 3 that union is v 2 v 3 v
5 which induce a click in the original
graph g so we add an edge there
and we continue this process until we
finish the
construction of the entire graph g prime
okay so that's it that's the entire
reduction
and note here that the number of
vertices in g
prime is exactly n as we claimed earlier
so before i go forward let me note here
that uh this is not an
original reduction by any means at all
as i stated earlier it has been used
in harness approximation before by
birmingham and schnitzker
who use it to prove hardness
approximation for
the clique problem and it has been
continued to use
uh until very recent work both for
clique and for densest case subgraph
another point i would like to note is
that uh in
an earlier work of alan et l who used
the planted clique hypothesis not the
strong each planetary hypothesis but the
original planetary hypothesis
to prove hardness of density subgraph
they also use a similar reduction
with just one different which is that
that subset
s i's are taken to be all
subsets of size l whereas for us here we
are
picking only some random subsets and
uh since alon l was looking for hardness
in terms of
the graph size and that result are
incomparable to us
so now let's prove the desired
properties of
our reduction starting with the
yes case so here recall that we have
that
t is drawn from the planted distribution
where the clique size
kappa is n to the point one
and we want to show that with probably
probability point nine
d prime doesn't contain a k clip
so here we will pick uh the
big n to be 10k times n to the
0.9 times l uh and not here that this is
still n to the order of l because uh
here
our k will be very small
and the proof of the completeness is as
follows
let's see be the click in g
of size n to the point one
notice that uh ignoring lower order term
for the moment
each set s i is a subset of
c with probability roughly n to the
minus
0.9 times l this is because each vertex
in
s i belongs to c with probability n to
the minus
0.9 so this means that
in expectation there will be 10k of the
subset
s i that are subsets of c
the or the click in the original graph g
and we can turn this to uh into a
probability statement
uh that with probability 0.9 at least k
of this subset s i's are subset of the
click c
in the original graph now
recall from our definition that when
s i union sj
induce a click in g we add an edge
between them
since these ksi's are subset of c
the union of each pair of them induce a
click in g
as a result these sis will form a k
click in the new graph g prime
and that's it that's the entire
completeness proof
let us now move on to the soundness
proof
recall again that in the soundness case
or the no case
we have that our graph g is drawn from
the
gn and a half the random distribution
and we would like to show that any k
will take subgraph of
g prime contains at most k
times log n over l edges with uh
probability 0.9
now the overall idea in showing this is
pretty simple
so we'll consider each sub graph that
exceeds this bound in other words is two
dense
in g prime and bound the probability
that
it exists in g prime and then we just
take the union bound over these
two dense subgraphs
so let us start with the formula how do
we bound
the probability that each two then sub
graph exists
so let's consider any possible k vertex
subgraph of g
prime with at least the times k edges
where
these are parameter will choose later
notice here that each edge in d prime
corresponds to
a click in g which is a union between
the two
subsets s i and sj
now since each of s i and sj has size
l these correspond to roughly l square
edges
in the original graph d now
since the subgroup that we are
considering contain these times k
edges and each h and g prime correspond
to roughly l square edges in g
this mean that the entire sub graph will
correspond to
roughly d times k times l square edges
in
the original graph t now this statement
that i just said actually doesn't follow
as trivially as i might have led you to
believe
and the reason is that uh each
in g might be might appear in
uh more than one pair of subsets sisj
so it might have been counted multiple
times in
our argument here however it turned out
to not be that big of a problem
uh because our set s i's are random and
we can show that for these random
subsets
the number of repetitions that we are
counting is
not too much and in fact the subgraph
still corresponds
to uh omega d times k times l square
edges
uh in the original graph t now finally
recall that the graph t is just drawn
from g n
and a half so each edge appears
independently with probability one half
so the probability of this sub graph
appearing in g
prime is only exponentially small in d
times k times l square
all right now we can move to the second
step and in the second step
notice here that the number of uh the
two dense sub graphs
is dominated by the choice the
number of choices for its vertices and
there are k vertices
so there are roughly big n to the order
of k
such sub graphs and this just equals to
little n to the order of k times l
so here we can use the union bound and
we can get that the probability that g
prime uh contains at least one of such
two dense subgraph
is n to the order of k times l times
exponential in minus d times k times l
square
so now if we pick d to be a sufficiently
large
constant times log n divided by
l then we have that this number is at
most point one
in other words uh with probability point
nine we have that any k
vertex sub graph of t prime contains
at most order of k times log n over l
edges and that concludes our soundness
proof
modulo some simple calculations those
are basically
all the technical components of our work
so let me conclude here
we propose uh vary and other planted
clean hypotheses which we call the
strong-ish planetary hypothesis
and prove several tight inner
proximability results and tight running
time lower bounds
using the new hypothesis there are quite
a few
research directions uh that might be
interesting to pursue here
first is can we get a tie-in
approximability ratios also in terms of
n
notice here that uh in our work here we
are we get titanium
results but only in terms of k it would
be interesting to strengthen this
and get time in approximately in terms
of n as well
another kind of more open direction is
to find more applications for the
strong each painted click hypothesis and
this also include applications that are
beyond harness approximation result
and finally it would also be interesting
to
prove our hardness results but under
different assumptions
such as a hardness of random csp for
example
and that's it thank you all very much
for your attention